peter parker and the girlfriend
I want you to find your friend
spider-man tell him to meet me
at the west side tower at three
o'clock i don't know where he is
find him
Welcome back everyone it's pizza time this
is going to be my new spider-man 3 video for
doctor octopus they just confirmed that alfred
molina is coming back from the tobey maguire
spider-man movies as his version of doctor octopus
just like jamie foxx is coming in as electro
there's so many more live-action spider-verse
easter eggs with this so we'll break it all
down if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos obviously
this is just the beginning it's going to get
even crazier as we learn more about the movie
here's what they want alright practicing and action
a target is the fuel that makes this
project go there are only 25 pounds on the planet
i want to thank harry osborne and oscorp
industries for providing it. Excellent Willem!
While i was making this video too it was also
reported that andrew garfield did sign a contract
to come back so i'll talk about that during the
video too you probably saw the news somewhere on
social media but it was hollywood reporter that
broke the news that alfred molina was coming back
he only appeared in spider-man 2 and the way that
movie ended at the time they tried to be kind of
ambiguous about what happened to him after he went
down in the water so i'll address that during the
video because everyone's kind of wondering how
they're going to explain him during the movie
because of what jamie foxx was posting like when
jamie foxx revealed that he was going to be in
spider-man 3 as electro he said that his costume
would not be blue making us think that he might
be a different mcu version of electro and not
his electro from amazing spider-man 2. so we'll
try to address that during the video because
most people are talking like this is going to
be him coming from the tobey maguire spider-man
movies because of a couple other rumored castings
but even if they changed the versions of their
characters just a little bit with both of them
added to the movie electro adopter octopus
even without Tobey maguire spider-man and
andrew garfield versions of spider-man appearing
on screen you can say that they have gone full
spider-verse with their easter eggs and references
i think we'd all expected some kind of spider-man
multiverse easter eggs at some level just because
they confirmed doctor strange was the big avengers
crossover character in spider-man 3 and it's
coming just a few months before doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness which is full-blown chaos
level multiverse story so it stands to reason that
there will be some multiverse stuff happening in
spider-man 3 and that'll be how they explain some
of these big twists the report about the other
characters that are supposedly coming back include
andrew garfield having signed his contract
apparently sony is still trying to work out
a deal with tobey maguire to come back but
that's expected to close sometime soon too
and emma stone and kirsten dunst are also expected
to cameo in some form or another as their versions
of gwen stacy and mary jane so number four the
report that they published doesn't specify if his
doctor octopus will be one of the villains of the
movie it's just as he's coming back as his doctor
octopus who was a villain in spider-man 2. but if
jamie foxx made it sound like his electro would be
one of the villains then it's a safe assumption
that Doctor octopus will also be a villain of
some sort when he shows up even without craven the
hunter or sandman we have enough characters for an
og version of the sinister six from the spider-man
comics couple minor changes but for the most part
relatively close to that original team doctor
octopus was sort of the last major puzzle piece
we were all hoping to eventually see in the
spider-man movies in the mcu not including
a version of green goblin could you imagine
what would happen if they suddenly announced
in a couple days though that willem dafoe was
coming back as green goblin i loved in spider-man
particularly playing the double roll everybody
thinks about the green goblin and that was fun
but the more interesting role was probably the
father but green goblin wasn't a member of the
sinister six not the original version of the team
it was Doctor octopus who put the team together
in the first place he recruited electro vulture
mysterio sandman and craven the hunter there have
been other versions of the team with different
rosters and we know there's supposed to be some
vulture sinister six easter eggs in the morbius
movie next year there's no sandman in the mcu yet
but we do have scorpion shocker the tinker because
i think we all believe that mysterio either
survived or there'll be a big twist and it'll be
william ginter riva pretending to be a new version
of mysterio because he's still all mysterio's tech
at the end of spider-man far from home so either
way you still have a version of that mysterio
number three this new doctor octopus report
doesn't say how much of the movie he's going to
be in only that he's in it is Doctor octopus so
there's so much plot that they already have to tie
up after spider-man far from home i would temper
your expectations i wouldn't expect him to be in
the entire movie maybe just a cameo scene or a few
scenes in service of the larger spider verse
crossover easter eggs it's also pretty clear
that they want to set up some sort of spider-man
sinister six movie in the future so a lot of these
other sinister six characters could just be in
the movie in service of continuing that storyline
really when the movie picks up the main plot
is spider-man still trying to clear his name
the whole world is after him and he just got
doxed to boot so aunt may is probably getting
the nasty end of that back at their apartment now
that everybody in the world knows where spider-man
lives the only places in new york city that
spider-man would actually be able to hide from
both the villains and the cops the fbi or the law
enforcement agencies would be secret bunkers or
labs that iron man has stashed around the city
or more likely the sanctum doctor strange knows
him from avengers infinity war in avengers endgame
even though he probably doesn't like him that much
he probably just tolerates him like why do i have
to babysit this kid they said that he'd be more
of a mentor to spider-man sort of replacing
iron man's role in that relationship during
the movie so even though he's mostly concerned
with giant dimensional multiverse level threats
spider-man stirring up the hornet's nest with
all the mysterio stuff around the world would be
enough to get his attention so it's likely being
as powerful as he is doctor strange knows the real
truth of mysterio's fake video it just reaches out
literally and metaphorically to help spider-man
during the movie i'm really hoping for a twist on
that loki joke from thor ragnarok where spider-man
just dips into an alleyway running from a crowd
and doctor strange opens a portal below him
dropping him in but instead of slamming on the
ground like loki because he's spider-man and
he's so balletic and graceful he just lands on
his feet it's also a cool way of calling back
to the creative use of spider-man portals during
avengers infinity war and that fight with thanos
with him just dipping in and out really easily
because he's so graceful i know we're all hoping
for tobey maguire andrew garfield cameos you
have to imagine three versions of spider-man
all doing that at the same time in a giant boss
fight speaking of multiverse though number two
when it comes to explaining how electro and doctor
octopus actually show up in the movie in whether
or not they're retconned mcu versions or they're
legit traveling the multiverse or spider-verse
because we're talking about spider-man movies
from the andrew garfield and Tobey maguire movies
i think they're going to invoke some of the
chaos in the multiverse that scarlet witch
said soft during the wandavision episodes that's
meant to be the beginning of this marvel phase 4
multiverse plot she messes with reality and
the multiverse to bring a version of vision
back to life because she just can't deal with
him being dead but in doing so as you would
expect causes a bunch of negative consequences
between realities and it just continues to get
worse and worse and worse with ripple effects
through the rest of the marvel phase 4 movies
and disney plus series as we go along in the
timeline then we reach peak multiverse chaos
in doctor strange 2. she's one of the main
characters during that movie doctor strange
is the main character in spider-man 3 so you can
kind of see how they're weaving this multiverse
plot along so it's pretty safe to assume that a
lot of the big twists will be multiverse twists
that's why i think they're trying to weave in
some spider-verse easter eggs with doctor octopus
and electro it would also be a really easy way to
explain how tobey mcguire and andrew garfield can
cameo in the movie as their versions of spider-man
even if it's only briefly it really does seem like
they're going to cameo now with all these other
characters coming back from other movies and i
just did a spider-man 3 video for a teaser that
sony accidentally released and also added a kimmel
video to that and in that he was trying to get
zendaya to talk about Tobey maguire during their
interview where are you you're in atlanta right
now shooting uh spider-man 3 correct correct
correct you could say that i know every it's very
secretive right yes everything is very secretive
is it called spider-man 3 because there are
three spider-men in the movie i can neither
confirm nor tonight you cannot get oh interesting
did you have did you have thanksgiving there in
atlanta yes we did we had a a bubble
thanksgiving with spider-man yeah i can't say
i was good that was good that's good yeah
cause i was wondering what you guys have
because i know Tobey maguire is a vegan and i was
wondering if he had like a tofurky or something
i have no idea you have no idea really i really
don't i really don't hey everyone oh peter sorry
i'm late it's a jungle out there i had to beat
an old lady with a stick to get these cramps
but number one if you're thinking about more
spider-verse easter eggs and solving the big
problems of the film spider-man still has to
clear his name one of the easy ways they could
do that is just have tobey maguire or andrew
garfield's version of spider-man take the fall
for tom holland's peter parker like it
wasn't him it was me i'm spider-man no
i'm spider-man it just becomes easier for him to
take his secret identity back and get people to
stop thinking he's spider-man when there are
other versions of spider-man swinging around
also consider that sam raimi mr spider-man himself
from back in the day from the tobey maguire movies
is directing doctor strange 2 so i'm also kind of
expecting some spider-man crossover easter eggs in
that movie as well they did the same thing with
thor ragnarok between the doctor strange movie
but post all your reactions in the comments
what do you want them to do with Doctor
octopus now that he is a confirmed mcu character
there is a really big disney investor meeting
tomorrow with a new Wandavision trailer probably
dropping in announcements on what's going on with
all the upcoming movies and disney plus series
so we'll probably get some footage for some of
that stuff so of course i'll be doing videos for
all that in my new mandalorian season 2 episode
7 video we'll post on friday just like normal so
as long as you have alerts enabled for my channel
you should see all those videos when i post them
but leave your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for that new spider-man 3
spider-verse trailer sony accidentally posted
and then quickly deleted and click here for
my new mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!